[Musique]
au début c'était comme un échappatoire
j'ai eu le choix ben entre la rue et me
consacrer à une passion et après ben
avec la famille avec les amis avec le
soutien des gens et ben j'ai trouvé ma
voie je dirais que ma motivation
aujourd'hui c'était
de s'accrocher de croire en rêve
[Musique]
au début ma montée
d'un salon bien même mon papa te dit Hey
là ça décalé encore la table la teigne
pour la première fois météo lycée
n'avait remporte la Biennale ici la
Biennale dense et là elle a pris un
autre
[Musique]
à la rencontre des personnes que bah
peut-être n'a pas eu cette chance là
comme moi au début façon de parler on a
fait une vidéo ici avec les personnes
portées d'handicap et l'énergie que
banane et
j'ai pas de mots
[Musique]
mon souhait le plus cher ça serait
d'ouvrir une école de danse accessible à
tout le monde qu'importe les moyens
qu'importe du physique mais accessible à
tout le monde voilà mes proches mais les
breaker mais mes sachets un petit peu le
Malo il y a la danse Mahoré le côté
malgache le côté afro le côté pop tout
ça au fait il fait aussi les qualités et
à la fois l'identité d'un danseur
paroles de David IBA tu es plus fort que
moi